[Music]
hello there february isn't usually seen
as a great month for gaming releases yet
this february may be the greatest month
in video game history it's so packed
with new games that many have been
delayed to avoid this month in
particular as a tradition if you don't
have money to spend this month i've
found two free games both with the
potential to take over the world so
let's crack on
first we have horizon forbidden west on
the playstation 4 and 5. eloy returns
and the story picks up after the events
of zero dawn back in 2017. eloy is
tasked with finding the cause of a
mysterious plague ravishing the lands as
the name suggests forbidden west takes
us to the california side of the old u.s
and along the way eloy will face off
with other tribes and more amazing
mechanical animals than ever before
we're gonna fight a mammoth and is that
a snake i can't wait for that fight
forbidden west's map is confirmed to be
larger than the previous game and more
dense with things to do than ever before
we have new traveling mechanics like
gliding and swimming and improved free
climbing which will let us get in places
we never could before oh and have you
seen the valor surge this may be the
most epic thing you'll see today horizon
forbidden west drops on friday february
18th on ps4 and ps5
[Music]
releasing on february 4th is another
sequel to a brilliant game dying light 2
stay human let's try to sum this up in
one sentence an action adventure
survival horror post-apocalyptic
first-person parkour simulator just the
free running part alone has over 3 000
different animations dying light is all
about risk reward as venturing out at
night time is far more dangerous than
the day as some enemies can only be
found during moonlight hours and
typically that's when the best loot is
on offer too that loot and scavenging
for crafting materials help us evolve
our weapons the in-game map is broken
into seven sections each controlled by a
different faction and we must decide if
we fight them or work with them this
leads to some difficult decisions as
your actions affect everyone leaving
devastation behind you helping one
faction could actually hurt another
faction dying light 2 can be played
alone but i highly recommend trying 4
player co-op it's a blood bath down like
2 stay human releases on february 4th on
playstation xbox pc and
switch arguably the biggest game to
release in 2022 is eldon ring the first
soulsborne game to be an open world i'm
sure you know someone who is obsessed
with from software games and their back
catalog including sakura demon souls
dark souls bloodborne so many great
games one after the other all of which
are brutal and could never be classed as
casual that said the previews for elden
ring tell us that this game is more
accessible to new players than ever
before but at its core it doesn't change
learn from your mistakes is the key to
elden ring knowledge of the landscape of
each encounter and understanding the
weapons and tools at your disposal game
of thrones writer george r.r martin is
on board to bring the character design
to life as only he can so if you like
managing stamina and magic with over 100
skills to unlock and master with
countless hours of potential gameplay
you should try eldon ring release on
playstation xbox and pc on february 25th
oh and this is another game that
supports four-player co-operative
shenanigans
have you heard of sifu a beat em up like
no other the premise sees a kung fu
student sent on a revenge mission after
his family is brutally slain off we go
with the only weapons our bare hands and
our kung fu knowledge we take down an
entire criminal syndicate we have over
150 moves to combo together as we break
the guards of enemies and then quickly
take them out but then this will happen
at some point we are going to be
overwhelmed and fall in battle luckily
we have a magic talisman that revives us
it also teaches us a little more kung fu
which is great but sadly it ages us too
this means our revenge attempt will be
completed in one day and also one
lifetime if we age too much the talisman
can't revive us anymore and we rest in
peace i'm super intrigued by sifu which
releases on february 8th on ps4 ps5 and
pc
move on to destiny 2. if you've been
living under a rock you may not know
that destiny 2 at its base at least is a
free-to-play game which you can grab
right now once you're addicted the
expansions are paid content like the
upcoming witch queen dlc bungie haven't
told us a great deal about this just yet
but we do know the new content includes
a new raid a reworking to the void
classes and a new weapon type the glaive
this is destiny's first ever first
person melee weapon the update will also
bring a new branch to the story as well
as quality of life changes and an
updated weapon crafting system too there
is still a great deal to learn about the
new expansion before its release on
tuesday the 22nd of february and
remember the base game is free if you
ever feel the urge to get into destiny
yourself
[Music]
speaking of free stuff let's do that now
check out this epic games and iron
galaxy have teamed up to create rumble
verse a free to play 40 player battle
royale with a difference there isn't any
guns and instead wwe style grapples are
needed to defeat your foes in an open
city where anything can be climbed and
cars are trampolines the art style is
reminiscent of fortnite which epic is
hoping will attract that audience but
it's the customization which looks the
most intriguing it's substantial with
countless elements to add to your
character to be unique this has a lot of
potential if the fighting feels fair and
fun and the battle royale elements don't
feel forced i have high hopes for
rumbleverse which is set to release for
free on february 15th unless issues
arise in the final steps of testing
those who want to play early you'll need
to pay for that but don't worry i've
paid for it so you don't have to and
i'll tell you all about the game before
it releases rumble versus here on
playstation xbox and on epic star for pc
players how do you feel about a free to
play melee battle royale i'd love to
know until then i'll see you on the 15th
oh and you should know that ps plus and
game pass isn't needed to play
free-to-play games
if that doesn't float your boat i have
another free game which is out right now
yu-gi-oh master duel it's suddenly
released without any fanfare a card
collecting game in which you battle
other players online i'm going to
struggle to explain this one as i'm not
a digital card battling game connoisseur
but i know this will be floating
someone's boat konami have confirmed
tutorials in-game will turn the most
newbie guy like me into a pro so if
you're on console pc or mobile phone you
can try it for free right now get your
yu-gi-oh on but always remember
free-to-play games want your money in
some way so be aware and you'll be okay
back to full price games now evil dead
the game if you're a fan of games like
friday the 13th predator hunting grounds
or dead by daylight you'll understand
the basic premise here asymmetrical pvp
with a big bad guy villain taking down
as many of the good guys in a team as
possible and all those people are taken
from the movies evil dead the game also
includes side missions and cooperative
missions with friends some are
completely solo adding a cinematic field
like the films it's the end of january
when i'm recording this right now and we
are still waiting for more information
all we know is evil dead the game is
coming sometime in february on
playstation xbox switch and pc just
enough time to watch the movies again if
you can't remember them for those who
want an interactive story you should
consider life is strange remastered
collection back in 2018 when episodic
adventures took over the world life is
strange was mind-blowing a detailed
story with branching options in
conversations which affect the direction
of the overall story there was also a
really cool rewind mechanic where if you
didn't like what happened in front of
you you could go back a few seconds and
change things life is strange taught me
one important life lesson something
positive in the short term can lead to
something absolutely terrible in the
future if you missed this story five
years ago i highly recommend living
through it now
and finally i couldn't decide between
olly ollie world and king of fighters 15
so here's both olly ollie world is a 2d
skateboarding game which has evolved
into an rpg the basics still remain
though keeping a combo going just like
tony hawk and king of fighters is the
return of a classic one-on-one fighter
before mortal combat and injustice were
a thing king of fighters was the main
opposition to street fighter the parry
system was its way to stand out back
then and it's back again in 15. so there
we have it 10 games that you should be
playing if you can afford to and have
more than 24 hours in your day thanks
for staying until the end if you are
still here let me know what the first
game you ever played was this may show
how old you are i'm adam you're awesome
i'll see you next time
[Music]